you with that giant black eye and then
you're on camera lat that day is insane
no I know and I broke this finger
earlier and uh you know and so they
don't it's kind of frowned upon you know
and uh uh at work but I had transition
like I still box because I was boxing a
lot too because I didn't that my
grandfather used to do that and I used
to do smokers which are like three round
fights over wild um Freddy roach's wild
Club um and I us to do that I'm a spar
tomorrow as a matter of fact said I said
I would I said I would show slow down my
wife wanted me to slow down but I'm like
ah makes me feel alive with your face I
torn my rotator cuff I've torn my
achilles I've torn my biceps you get
surgery for that yeah fool this whole
thing came off what are you talking
about the whole thing all these I had to
get major surgeries you know broke my
fingers and all that and I'm like I
don't know when my body's completely
broken down and decp it then I'll start
playing golf but no it makes me feel
young makes me feel
[Music]
alive